les chéris ce matin sont tenus les
obsèques de notre ami il ment
journaliste compagnon jean pierre
pernaut c'est vrai que c'était
incroyable on ait eu enfin on était tous
très émus et valérie était là bien sûr
bernard il y avait delphine il y avait
eu guillaume et c'est vrai que si on
était tous très très ému d'avoir
accompagné jean pierre il y avait
énormément de monde ce matin à la
basilique sainte clotilde à paris vous
allez voir toutes les images évidemment
son amour pour les régions la france
profonde son talent son parler vrai
jean-pierre bien sûr va nous manquer et
dans un instant vous allez voir tous les
moments de cette cérémonie cette
cérémonie qui a été orchestrée par
l'abbé de la morandais vous savez qu'on
adore la bella marrant d ici qui est
extraordinaire un de tolérance de
vraiment je sais c'est un garçon
vraiment qu'on aime et il a été
exceptionnel ce matin regardez c'est lui
qui avait fait le mariage d'ailleurs
d'eux
l'a dit d'ailleurs ce matin petit récap
et il sera avec nous et ainsi que
philippe candeloro qui étaient là
également ce matin c'est parti
le 2 mars 2000 monde de jean pierre
pernaut le présentateur emblématique du
jt de 13h de tf1 nous quitter la mort de
jean pierre pernaut l'ex présentateur du
13 heures de tf1 s'est éteint à l'âge de
71 ans il restera comme l'homme qui a
inventé un nouveau aujourd'hui une
annonce qui a bouleversé de nombreux
français ceux qui l'ont côtoyé au plus
près j'ai perdu en copain j'ai perdu un
ami j'ai perdu et mauron mon frangin ce
matin ses obsèques se tenait la musique
de sainte clotilde dans le 7e
arrondissement de paris nombreuses
personnalités étaient présentes sur
place dont ses fidèles confrères du
groupe tf1 qui ont travaillé durant des
années à ses côtés c'est à la fois un
extraordinaire journalistes un ami cher
et un type formidable sa femme nathalie
et ses enfants étaient aussi présents
pour saluer la mémoire de jean pierre et
lui dire un dernier au revoir
[Musique]
merci à l'abbé de la morandais d'être
avec nous ce soir vous avez orchestré ce
la cérémonie ce matin merci à philippe
d'être là également vous étiez aux
obsèques ce matin est énormément de deux
mondes voilà des anonymes des
personnalités tout le monde est revenu
et
venues d'ailleurs à l'abbé de la
morandais
faut chaud ce matin quand je vous ai
entendu voilà dire au revoir comme nous
tous âges en pire je vous dis je faisais
encore mal je vous ai pas senti triste
matin parce que vous connaissez bien
jean-pierre oui je vous ai sentis plein
d'espoir
alors
je les ai connus à voir qui je reconnus
ouais une certaine manière
moi j'ai fait ma première émission de
télé ça dira rien aux plus jeunes de 4
que cinq colonnes à la une alors 62
isabelle
bond et donc j'ai connu ce monde là
pendant le concile à rome il ya beaucoup
de journalistes de presse écrite et des
médias il y avait les gens du monde du
figaro et cetera donc on travaille
thomas habitués à ce monde-là
jamais rêvé de faire carrière médiatique
alors dit il que rennes plus médiatique
de forces n'était pas c'est pas un but
c'était pas quand on est prêtes faut pas
faire carrière là bien sûr c'est pas le
but on est militaire ont fait carrière à
les ambassadeurs ont fait carrière on
est journaliste pour fait carrière on
est un grand sportif ont fait carrière
on essaye j'ai pas de but non et donc
celles sur les circonstances qui amène
sa et les circonstances pour moi c'était
alors j'étais un peu rodé pendant le
compte il parce que moi m'a fait faire
du direct deux heures de direct les
obsèques de jean xxiii à l'époque haut
rhin n'ont jamais l'ex disent ah
et puis ensuite
moi j'ai fait la guerre d'algérie alors
c'est vrai que j'appris n'a pas fermé ma
gueule mais j'ai été témoin de la
torture donc j'ai ouverte on m'a dit de
yom après j'ai été témoin du drame des
harkis on me dit fermer votre gueule et
donc je me suis servi j'ai appris à me
servir des médias pour les harkis mais
on pas pour soi ça n'a aucun intérêt
puis après on connaît tous chemins
blancs et on rentre dans leur système
alors il y avait énormément de
personnalités ce matin
pour rendre hommage un dernier hommage à
jean-pierre regarder
et michel drucker convoi arrivait
en ce moment même l'épousé du président
de la république qui voit là comme
c'était annoncé qu'en dise on la voit
non loin du président sarkozy evelyne
dhéliat arrive à l'instant qui
évidemment fait la météo de pleyel aussi
très longtemps sur tf1 karine le
marchand vous le voyez fait son entrée
on voit sébastien cauet qui arrive ou de
personnalités sont attendues notamment
et faire de la rédaction de tf1 on a peu
parlé des rédacteurs en chef dé reporter
qui sont venus ici rendre un dernier
hommage
énormément de monde un qui était là ce
matin valérie oui mais vraiment ce qui
était formidable c'était que c'était une
des funérailles à son image c'est à dire
atteint la taille humaine s'était pas
les funérailles d'une star c'était les
funérailles d'un homme qui par ailleurs
était une star et aimé par beaucoup et
donc c'était des funérailles qui lui
ressemblait jeu se trouvait philippe tu
étais proche de la famille père n'ont
pas tes proches de fun je suis pas celui
qui connaissait mieux moi j'ai ce matin
c'est important pour toi d'être là bas
je gérais j'ai toujours eu de la chance
d'être d'avoir été invité à la certaine
malheureusement obsèques où sa cérémonie
de gens décédés connu parce qu'en fin de
compte c'est les gens je me sentais
proche jean pierre je suis pas tous les
dimanches j'étais pas tous les dimanches
chez eux en train de manger mais c'est
quelqu'un quand je les croise et j'ai
l'impression qu'il me parlait comme un
coma son fils quoi c'est à dire c'est
c'était très cool della le premier la
première rencontre et ce matin comme l'a
dit valérie en fait c'est que j'ai vu
plein de gens vrais comme ils disent et
et j'ai entendu beaucoup de choses qui
ressemblait beaucoup à ce que je pouvais
entendre de mon père et de ce que je
pourrais attendre de moi aujourd'hui
donc finalement jeu j'étais très ému
parce que bon même si c'est pas ma
famille et je remercie nathalie ne m'a
pas fait de m'avoir donné la chance
d'être à cette cérémonie parce que la
baie a été très très très sympa aussi
très très cool non mais c'est important
dans une cérémonie de padt ok c'est un
décès bien sûr mais c'est triste oui
mais je trouve que la manière dont il a
abordé la cérémonie ça a permis à tout
le monde c'est important pour vous
l'abbé de la morandais de données voilà
de 2,2 c'est vrai que je lisais si on
n'avait pas l'air non n'avais pas
l'impression d'être à des obsèques parce
que vous et y est extrêmement joyeux non
alors pourquoi s'inquiéter parce que moi
j'étais au mollet du monde politique
donc j'étais recteur de la basilique et
grâce à chirac on a tous restaurés le
chauffage etc tout aménagé mettez donc
que je connaissais le monde politique
donc crié sarko carla bruni qui est
enfin tout le choc est hélas ça dérange
pas je les connais je les côtoie donc
penser ce n'est pas roi ça comme les
autres tiens qui avait énormément de
monde et notamment des politiques
c'était là puisqu'il y avait valérie
pécresse rachida dati il y avait
également christian estrosi inquiéter
martin exactement il martin oui bien sûr
le patron le propriétaire de tf1 et
parmi les personnalités politiques la
présence la plus importante enfin
c'était bien sûr brigitte macron il y
avait nicolas sarkozy l'ancien président
de la république qui est venu rendre
hommage à jean pierre en compagnie de
carla toujours très sympathique qui est
en pleine interview il a salué brigitte
matin
c'était un homme bon
bienveillant gentil et pendant de
longues années de maquilleurs
professionnels
jeu à faire des gens qui n'étaient pas
toujours bon bienveillant gentil proche
des gens et avec carla nous avons voulu
honorer sa dépouille et sa famille
est-ce que vous regardiez le jt de 13
heures lorsque vous étiez président
monsieur sarkozy
bien sûr pourquoi pourquoi ne pas le
regarder naturellement moi j'aime bien
regarder les gens qui sont proches des
autres et qui parlait de la france telle
qu'on aime la france profonde merci
c'est vrai que ces nombreux hommages 1
ce matin alors qu'à plusieurs reprises à
des chansons de johnny hallyday qui ont
ressorti dans l'église et du père noël a
eu une affection toute particulière pour
johnny hallyday nous avait raconté une
anecdote il s'était rendu un de ses
concerts dans le public il avait été
ovationné par le public parce qu'au
final il y avait le même public que
johnny hallyday tout le monde aimait
johnny et tout le monde aimait et m e
jean-pierre il faut savoir que c'est
vrai que ça 10 11h10 que le cercueil de
jean pierre est arrivé dans la basilique
sainte-clotilde dans le 7e
arrondissement c'était très émouvant de
voir nathalie et les quatre enfants de
jean pierre réunies autour du cercueil
il est rentré sur une chanson de johnny
exactement telle ni edith piaf j'ai
regardé l'avenir tout simplement qui
arrive maintenant pour
pour le début de cette série n'est pas
d'aller marquer pernaut et qui en effet
est là pour cet ultime hommage à son à
son mari le recueillement devant le
cercueil de de jean pierre pernaut qui
dans quelques instants va faire son
entrée dans la basilique sainte clotilde
à paris
nathalie marquay et ses enfants entrent
dans la basilique pour cet ultime
hommage
oui valérie je sais que c'est y est très
très ému ce matin en valais way qui est
en pleurs un oui très ému bah oui parce
que
jamais jamais infiniment nathalie ses
enfants jean pierre a été un des
premiers que j'ai croisés sur ma route
professionnelle à tf1
il m'a immédiatement
pris dans sa famille et jean-pierre il
aimait où il aimait pas il m'a
immédiatement aimé et il m'a donné cette
semaine là et voilà c'était oui il avait
de la mangue oui les deux change qui
nous rapprochaient c'est que
j'ai bien de son terrain territoire
potentiel damien mouachah breton en exil
à paris j'ai dû m'y accroche en lozère
et donc quand il ya un problème avec les
paysans éleveurs de moutons par exemple
eh bien je peux appeler jean pierre je
n'ai pas appelé stéphane bern ou thierry
ardisson et après jean-pierre pour le
duo maia des éleveurs qui attaquaient
par les lois sur les bobos urbains ils
comprennent rien toi tu vas comprendre
et il me rappelez vous
il ya des devoirs
il a d'autres qualités que c'était pas
d'aussi faut l'appeler siens à château à
rénover mais ça sert et que si c'est
plus rageant que dure empêché chacun
2007 je célèbre et non pas son mariage
parce qu'il était divorcé donc on
affaire n'a que deux divorcés remariés
c'était très mal vu à l'époque par ma
hiérarchie parce que or moi je pense que
il ya des échecs dans la vie ici en
croyant qu'un rien peut nous empêcher
des croyants de rassembler ensemble et
de prier non le to7 pas faire un
simulacre
on n'a pas fait d'émules donc on a
célébré nathalie est très croyante mais
alors ce qui m'a surpris ce matin
agréablement et beaucoup de communes
gens qui comme ulysse a alors ce matin
comme on l'a dit il y avait énormément
de personnalité beaucoup de politiques
il y avait aussi il ya des pleins
d'animateurs qui ont pris la parole il
ya de michel drucker denis brogniart
jean pierre foucault jean pierre
foucault qui a fait un discours
magnifique vraiment
exceptionnel encore une fois jean pierre
c'est vrai que tout le paf admirer jean
pierre pernaut et vers 13h40 après deux
heures de metz est à l'horaire vers
lequel l'egypte et finissait son 13
heures le cercueil est sorti de l'église
sous les applaudissements avant de
partir pour une inhumation dans
l'intimité regarde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas du comme une coutume très
française d'applaudir dans l'année c'est
vrai mais à rome on le fait à la
basilique saint-pierre tombe on
applaudit c'est chez les romains ils
sont plus enthousiastes donc ça marche
bien ça permet à chacun anonyme ou pas
connu de à léon parti j'ai maintenant il
ya des il ya beaucoup de choses qu'on
fait réagir il ya stéphane guillon
notamment stéphane guillon qui a réagi
keddy la guerre diffusé non stop sur les
chaînes info depuis dix jours la guerre
s'arrête quelques heures le temps de
retransmettre les obsèques de jean
pierre pernaut on dira ce qu'on voudra
mais poutine s'est parfois avoir du
coeur c'est vrai que c'est un truc très
mal passé une ville non mais il ya des
moments où il faut se taire en commune i
ce sont des instants solennels partagé
par par tous les français mais excusez
moi mais qui ferme sa gueule quoi ça
vous me choque énormément ça je trouve
pas ça drôle du tout ça me choque est
allé moment où on respecte la douleur on
se voit là on se paie on fait silence on
communie on pense en tout cas et on
écrit surtout pas ces conneries
merci de votre tu es d'accord vous êtes
d'accord
non c'est vrai que c'est un peu choquant
qu est-ce que vous avez ce que quelques
derniers mots pourriez nous dire ce soir
parce que c'est vrai que c'était c'était
vraiment survie c'était un des obsèques
mais
franchement vous avez je vous le dis
vous nous avez tous détendu parce qu'on
était tous très plein d'émotions voilà
parce qu'on aimait tous jean pierre et
c'est vrai que je trouve que c'était
voilà c'était il y avait des témoignages
incroyable de beaucoup les enfants c'est
quand il est incroyable voilà et c'est
vrai que tous les enfants y déversant
formidable je voudrais vous dire vous
aussi un aménagement et vous avez été
vous avez été exceptionnel ce matin
voilà je voulais vous dire mais avec
votre travail non à la fois faut
beaucoup préparé ouais et en même temps
elle capable d'être spontané ouais c'est
sûr quand je vois brigitte m'a quand je
veux votre votre présence nous honore
vos premières dames de france et puis je
rajoute et peut-être votre brillant
aussi quoi
sourire
je voudrais rendre hommage tout de même
à notre amie valérie bénaïm je dirais
pourquoi parce que nathalie nous a
demandé de faire un discours
l'accepter je n'ai pas eu le courage de
le faire je n'ai pas voulu le faire je
me sentais totalement l qu'incapables a
beaucoup parlé tous les deux et nathalie
été très touché que tu le fasses je dis
bravo parce que moi j'ai été incapable
de parler sur scène donc vraiment bravo
net valérie vraiment c'est très touchant
c'était terrible de faire c'est un beau
il y avait tellement d'amour il avait un
très beau disque mais moi je sais très
rare dans des messe d'obsèques qu'on
entende des musiques de chansons
populaires nous dit quand on n'a que
l'amour au moment de la communion qui a
été jouée deux fois mois jamais ça m'a
j'ai trouvé ça absolument bouleversant
laissez le moi encore un peu mon dieu
via ce qui c'était absolument magnifique
aussi
oui oui c'est ça et est en fait toute la
france admet jean pierre pernaut parce
que c'est l authenticité vraiment à la
télé ce qui se fait quand même très
rarement et même encore aujourd'hui et
il est inimitable et moi ce que j'aimais
beaucoup aussi c'était le couple qu'il
représentait avec nathalie c'était très
différent et en même temps très
complémentaires et je pense que tous les
français étaient vraiment toujours
touché et ça les faisait sourire ce
couple qu'ils avaient ensemble et il ya
plusieurs familles en fête il ya la
famille tf1 il ya sa famille qui ont
pris la parole et aussi la famille des
miss france sylvie tellier a fait un
beau discours et c'est vrai qu'on était
plusieurs miss france pourquoi parce que
c'est la personne qui vous fait le tout
premier jt quand on est élu miss france
il a choisi impliqués dans cette famille
là et c'est pour ça qu'on lui en est
très très reconnaissant tout parce que
c'est le premier regard qu'on a vu
qu'ils qui nous faisait comprendre allez
maintenant tu vas aussi à la télé
c'était beau
m